Oh you've heard of oxytocin?
Oh you love it because you think it's so lovely?
Yeah think again.
Hello hello Laci Green here for Dnews.
Guys I love me some oxytocin.
We've talked about this neurotransmitter before.
It's that chemical that's released in your
brain when you hug someone, when you're cuddling,
after you orgasm, even after childbirth.
It's a love hormone.
It makes people feel all warm and nice inside
and it's said to promote social bonding between
people.
So basically it's a hormone that you makes
like people more, I mean what's not to like
there.
Except that there might be one little thing
that's not to like: the teensie tiny little
thing of oxytocin making you feel fear and
anxiety and burning bad memories into your
brain.
Dude, that's not cool!
A new study at Northwestern that came out
this week is revealing the evil side of oxytocin
which up to this point has been unbeknownst
to us.
Researchers took two sets of mice, one set
without oxytocin receptors and one set with
lots of extra receptors.
They put the mice into a cage with agressive
mice.
They're trying to stress them out right?
And then they gave them a break.
When they reintroduce the mice to the aggressive
cage, the mice on oxytocin were totally freaked
out.
They knew it was coming, they were super stressed,
and they were not having it.
But the mice without the oxytocin were chill,
almost like they had let go and forgot about
the previous experience.
The scientists think this happened because
there's this little signaling molecule in
your brain called the Extracellular Signal-Regulated
Kinase or ERK for normal people that can't
remember long words.
After you have a bad social experience that
signal activates the fear pathways in the
brain and it gets all crazy in there for about
six hours after the experience.
The ERK is an important part of how we regulate
fear in our brains and it appears that oxytocin
activates it for even longer which ultimately
makes it harder to recover from the negative
experience you had.
So this is kind of a big deal because scientists
have been looking into using oxytocin to treat
anxiety disorders.
Like I'm just guessing here, but it's probably
not gonna be very effective to give people
with really bad anxiety drugs that will make
their brains have really bad anxiety.
It's just a hypothesis I have about this,
because science.
The researchers say that using oxytocin for
anxiety treatment may not be entirely out
of the question, though, given all its other
good effects that come about when social circumstances
are different.
You know when you're having sex instead of
being put in a cage with a bunch mean ol'
mice.
The key here may be that it depends on when
the oxytocin is taken and what the context
is.
Anyhow I'm pretty sad about this finding.
I thought that oxytocin was the one thing
in the world that I could love unconditionally.
Nothing lasts forever guys.
That's what I learned today.
Thanks for joining me peeps and hey, if you
haven't already you should be our friend on
Twitter @Dnews.
I swear we don't bite.
Well I don't bite.
I can't say the same for Trace and Anthony.
We'll see you next time.